so who wins in a fight uh John Wick or
Tyler Rick
that's like the greatest question of all
time
because I I mean that's tough
because I was uh you know part I'm
partial to the character of Tyler Rick
and
take away all right I'm gonna take away
John Wick's bulletproof suit and I'm
gonna give it to Tyler Rick the dudes a
bit you can dude's a badass so there's
no there's no debate there's no you
don't I mean you know what I mean like
if you weren't the director you you know
okay so you want me to just put just be
like a fan remove myself like you know
like like looking at it from like action
looking at it from everything being
honest do you think Tyler has this in
the bag no like no one John Wick is a is
a verb now like he's like to John Wicks
I'm like it's a thing he that's a he's a
legend
even he's a legend on screen in his own
movies and yet he's a legend now as a
like a action icon so no that dude
doesn't go down without a fight but the
fourth movie proves he can go down and
we've proven that our guy can be killed
and brought back from the dead so you
gotta give it to Tyler Rick a long
hard-fought battle to be sure but I
think you gotta go with Tyler Rick
Okay I accept that I think that if I
asked Chad he would probably say Wick of
course I mean of course he would and he
probably wouldn't even be a long heart
if he's like no I'm Wick in five you
know five seconds but
I'm just trying to imagine two of you uh
uh craft how each of you would uh craft
that action set piece